as we design and build autonomous
vehicle systems here at MIT and as we
study real-world naturalistic driving we
begin to understand that it may be one
two three four decades before we're able
to build autonomous vehicles that can be
fully autonomous without integrating the
human being before then we have to
integrate the human being whether as a
driver as a safety driver on telly
operator for that at the very beginning
at the very least the autonomous vehicle
needs to be able to perceive the state
of the driver as we look at the recent
case the tragic case of the pedestrian
fatality in Arizona we can see that the
perception of what the driver is doing
or they're looking on the road or not is
a critical importance for this
environment so we'd like to show to you
the Glantz region classification
algorithm running on the video of the
drivers face and also in the near future
we're going to make the code open source
available to everybody together with an
archived submission in hopes that
companies and universities testing
autonomous vehicles can integrate it
into their testing procedures and make
sure they're doing everything they can
to make the testing process as safe as
possible let's take a look to the left
is the original video in the middle is
the detection of the face region that is
then fed to the glass classification
algorithm is a sequence of images to the
neural network and then the neural
network produces in the output a
prediction of where the driver is
looking that's shown to the right
the current glass region that's
predicted whether it's Road left-right
rear view mirror center stack instrument
cluster then auto glance duration
whenever the driver is looking off-road
that number increases we run this glass
classification algorithm on this
particular video to show that is a
powerful signal for an autonomous
vehicle to have especially in the case
when a safety driver is tasked with
monitoring the safe operation of the
autonomous vehicle